"Welcome to instant death before we begin you have to accept these terms: I won't flip out
I will not destroy my computer, and I will always remember there is no checkpoint."
Okay, hello, everybody my name is markiplier and welcome to instant death now instant death touts itself is a very difficult game
I don't know about that. I'm not 100% percent sure so we'll find out what happens. It's a first-person
Rage game, but I never trust anything, that's
Touted to be a difficult game
We're just gonna see exactly how tough you can be and apparently that's not very.. green colors alright safe
AYE! okay well.
pop
pop pop
Okay, easy enough enter the portal to pass the level okay easy enough, okay
Let's do this for real Z this time level two orbs. Okay. Why do I need orbs?
Collect three orbs to win the level it's like the world's hardest game. I see how you are
Okay, well this isn't so bad. I can dig it easy Z alright. Let's do this bridge, okay?
Whoo you you you pew yep
Easy peasy, yawn-a-rama. Oh, this is so easy. Oh, this is the easiest thing I've ever seen ah
I tripped my massive balls over that one. All right. I see what you do. I see how you do game
ha ha ha
No, that's fine
All right, yes easy peasy lemon squeezy
All right, good. Good. Good. Rotating cubes Hey. What could be so bad about that one?
What could be so bad hey you get back down here? Let me up here. Okay? Not so bad
Okay, oh the first person's gone. Whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa? Hey whoa?
That was not fair why?
Well, that's not good
Yeah, oh come on oh
I hate this okay, right there safe. I see it
Okay, right there safe, okay?
Just walking along the path whoa don't like that
Okay, that's it come on
Dick hole dick hole dill weed
Hey pull the clothes on that one. Oh god
Okay, easy easy easy easy easy. I got this oh, no, please okay
Got it got it got it got it got it. Okay. All right now so bad bridge part two
How did you start it with him running away from me, hey back here
Please may I mother may I you think you can mess with the likes of me. Do you even know who I am?
My name is mawkipler! no no no please
AHH!  OOOOOOO
nope
wwaaAAHHH
Come on all right no whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa?
Whoa easy easy like it tweren't nothing like it like it weren't
naAAAHHH ohh
All right like it well doesn't help no. Hey. What the fuck huh you're fast. Why were you fast?
Jeezums
You no no no no ah it's so fast. It's so fast. It's so fast ooh. Why is it so?
eeeuuUUUH
Okay, god. I don't like you
Why are you so fast? Yeah? This is gonna be the the episode of me making moose noises all day long, okay?
Well, you didn't come all the way over here. You sank approve
NooOOOOO
Fucking come on oh
Sack of poop
*thumping music in back*
AHHH Come on
Come on. I had that
eugghh AYE
Okay, we're fine. Everything's fine. No excuse me. Sorry pardon - mwah
Mwah whooah pardane Mwoah! Pardan Mwah!
Jeezums I can't-nOOO come on
You're not even giving me a goddamn chance. you peice a poop
oooOH. Batch, batch, batch (bitch) Biznatch! Oh batch
No! C-What the fuck I did that again, I did that agaAiN!
no, aAAAH
Fuck big hairy, baba
Ganoush you're gonna taste the oh I was gonna say something along lines taste my victory or taste my sweaty balls. I don't know
uuUH. Okay, I don't know HOWIMALIVE but I'll take it whoa I'll take it. I'm gonna be a bag chooser
Okay, I made that finally oh
*Marks loud mating call*
God moose mating calls all day long at least please. Please don't shorn this shit off my
*various cries mixed with fear* Im so scareddd *more yells of fear*
Okay, we're fine. We're fine easy-peasy
wooAAHAAAHHH
*More of Marks Mating Call*
Haha, I hate that! how? can I duck? can IduUck?! can I duck!
Whatever, I don't
oh
Okay well then oh
NO NO NO NO
You piece of shit god fucking damn it oh
eeeyuoooohoho
AAYyooo
I hate that all of that oh
noOOOO! God DAMNIT! FuckING hEeELLLLL
EUUGHHH
I don't know how I am Alive, but I will take it
*quietly muttering to himself*
Wait
*more thumping music*
Yo- ARGHHH, I made it okay, I made it hood boy. I am sweating up a storm here
*crying? sounds of fear*
Faster cubes faster cubes. Oh okay? Well this ain't no fucking like I said you ain't no canoe I
smelt that deaf
*high pitch* hoookay maybe I should take my time
*Pure concentration and fear*
All right boy I am VERY afraid
Okay, I'll miss that entirely that's fine that means. I'll miss everything else enTIRELLYY
DUrrrhh, Dur
Okay.... Ahh
uuGHH
*mark making various caveman noises and grunts*
*screams*
Okay, I'm fine. I'm fine. It's all good. It's all good. its easy its easy its easy
Baby spin, what's spinning? I don't see no spin. I don't see no spin I
*dissapointed sigh*
Don't see no- ahh god damnIT I don't see no-FUCK. I don't see
nothin somebody touch em I spin GATS how in the
euu
Okay
Don't like you. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, what is that? What is that oh?
ughHHH
Okay, so it doesn't
Doesn't it doesn't reach? It's okay?
Just got a good where am I safe right here? Okay?
nuzzled up against the bosom
wooOOOO
Okay
woooOOOOO
*more screams*
Okay, I don't think the screaming is helping, but I like it
*screaming*
*more screams*
Okay oh -giggles-
Whoa hey whoa hey whoa
Okay ease oh god. No. No nOO NOO
first try baby oh
NOO OHH GAWD FUCKING NOO! NOOOOHOHO *pained noises* noo-hohoo
Fucking god damn it of course of course. I do of course. I choke. Oh, ah
Fucking hell it's Oh easy peasy
easy
No easy peasy okay. I got this all I got to do is get across the pillars. Just right
like a
Like a BAWSE
euuugh. euu-AHHH
Come OOHOHOHOONNN
No matter, what ah
Come on just jump jump jump you bastard all right spinny bastard the blender of death
It's all good. I got it oh
AWEHH
Right on my nards, it's easy it's easy I got what I need again
aaHHH NO NO!
*cries of anger*
comm onnn
Come on come on Big Boy show them what you're worth
Okay, yes, please don't fuck it up
aAGHHHH yeaaAAAAAA *slightly insane laughter*
*pained laughing*
Oh no
Remember where the orbs are
I Don't think I want that. why do I want to remember where the orbs are? why do I?
*fearful laughter*
im gonna lose my mIND okaAYYyy
owahhhH *tiny voice* I don't remember where the orbs are! What do you mean remember where the orbs are? WheRe Are ThE OrbS! I DuNnO
Oh, I see an orb! yay
one one
Okay great
God one. Oh, there's two okay. Give me a third ha ha I found you
Last one, okay, I just got to make it back now easy enough
*mark imitates monkey, slowly getting louder*
Why am I running oh
There's no need to run in the hallways
Okay, Oh
God ah my brain ah my brain my brain my iris
no time for death laser I
Gahhh I give up! I Give uhuhup
Yeah, I just see what the death laser is I'm not gonna make oh do I need to remember because oh ah I see
Okay
it's the same oh, it's the same orb position but
Now there's a death laser is what you're saying. Okay. All right. Well time for death laser
Looks like I'm going to be lasered to death, oh shit. Well, yeah
Well laser is activated
Well that's not good
Okay, where is it? Where's the laser?
*thumping music*
ooaHHH OHHHH
Okay, that's the laser okay. All right that one hurts my eyes. I think I'm done for now so that is
Instant death, lives up to his name
Very difficult very difficult, but not too bad. It's pretty good so anyway
Thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought of this game down in the comments below
I'll provide a link to this game if you want to bash your head against this proverbial wall
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know if you got other difficult games that you want me to play and possibly rage at so
Thanks again, and as always I will see you in the next video.
Buh BYEE!!
*outro music*